Um, when I was doing, I was thinking about this when I was a kid. Um,
I, the earliest memory you have, do you remember the earliest memory you have?
It's like, it's like hard to remember beyond before, like three, you know,
I remember when my, my brother was delivered. Um,
they say that like a, baby's a pizza,
but I remember when my brother was born and he came home and
he was in the car and I asked my mom because I was sitting next to me and he was
in the car seat and I was like, why does he have wrinkly hands? And my mom said,
what? And he uses his fingers all wrinkly. And my mom was like, Oh,
that happens to babies because they're, you know, that's just their,
their skin isn't ready yet or some. I remember that. And then I also remember,
uh, that day when my brother got home, uh, my grandpa got me a He-Man toy.
And when they gave me the He-Man toy and they said, Oh, Chris, isn't that cool?
I said, yeah, but he just got me that because he's here.
And I pointed to my brother, is this smart as a three and a half year old,
because they're trying to make me feel good and also worth something.
Even though my brother was in the world now, and he's still,
and he's still my thunder and it's all good.
But that day he stole my thunder because he was born. Okay.
But I also remember a time.
One of the other earliest memories I ever had was when I was in my bedroom as a
young, young kid, young boy, um, there were,
I had crayons in this yellow box. I forget what the other box was called,
but you would unlatch the box, open it up.
And they were open and it took the crowns off.
And I started drawing on the wall and my parents came in later and they were
like, Oh.
Oh God, what the did you do? You drew all over the wall.
I remember having the feeling,
thinking what you can't draw.
You can't call her on the wall. I remember feeling like, Oh,
I didn't mean to do anything wrong, dude. How crazy is that?
That I remember a time learning about how,
like, I didn't know, it was bad to color on the wall.
And that was when I learned it was bad to deface stuff. That's,
I felt good that I remembered that. I remember thinking like, Oh my God,
I didn't mean to do something bad. Why is this thing though?
Okay, well, this is breaking, but we'll fix it. One fire literally just goes,
Oh, um, but yeah, I remember that.
What's your earliest memory tweet me, but you know what? I don't give a,
but still you should think about it for yourself because you know, if it's,
when you were like 12, you got huge problems or you're trying to hide something.
Um.
Mm.
This is another thought I had that I never thought about,
but like we have balls and a Dick, you know, guys,
and like, think about how uncomfortable that is for real,
like, you don't think about how uncomfortable is it because it just how you are.
But think about if you just balls and didn't exist.
And then all of a sudden we just got balls,
or we would never not think about it every second of the day, we'd be like, Oh.
They'd be like, yo, you want to go grab a soda out of the fridge? You'd be like,
ah, I got this balls and Dick, I don't know, man.
I just want to be careful, you know, can we Postmates? It you'd be like, yeah,
but not right to your chair and be like, all right, I'll go get a,
I'll tell you what, when I'm hungry, I'll get up.
Because then I got to get food and the drink,
that's crazy that we have balls and Dick that's insane that we just have this
target in the middle of our bodies that can be lightly brushed up against
and ruin our hour. That's insane. And we just have them.
Girls don't have them, bro. If a girl gets kicked in the, in the, you know,
in the, I don't like to say it like this, but if a girl gets kicked on the,
then she gets, she's like, Oh, but it hurts. Like she gets punched in the arm.
If you get kicked in the balls, it hurts.
Like you get kicked in your nucleus dude.
You didn't kick the nucleus.
That is probably would have hurt as much.
It probably hurts more than if someone were to reach inside and squeeze your
brain. And we just have them on us. That's.
Jesus Christ should have made some protective gear. You know,
we had to do it manually as humans. We had to make a jock strap, bro,
Jesus, get on it.
We got balls on the outside, come on, bro.
Make a football helmet, you know, give us football helmets over our balls.
And we could have different teams and was like, Oh, you got all,
you got the Eagles. I would, I would get the Viking.
I would like to get the Vikings. I would like to have purple ones, a purple one.
You know.
Anyway,
that's all I'm saying is you don't realize how dainty balls are,
uh, until you think about what if we just got them.
Yeah.
And that's probably the most important thing I possibly said on this whole
podcast today.
Or maybe even ever remember that episode one 26. I think
so. Yeah. Watch out for your balls dude. Girls don't get it too.